ivy league presidents are scrambling to
save their jobs after disgracing
themselves for failing to call out
anti-Semitism on their campuses
University of Pennsylvania president Liz
McGill has been asked to resign by the
board of pens Warton business school
over her testimony and for good reason
the school is losing out on a100 million
donation from a donor who was quote
appalled by the university stance on
anti-Semitism Miguel has since tried to
walk back her remarks Harvard president
Claudine gay is also doing damage
control telling her schools paper quote
I am sorry words matter when words
amplify distress and pain I don't know
how you could feel anything but regret
even kamla's husband is trashing them
we've seen the presidents of some of our
most elite
universities literally unable to
denounce calling for the Gen side of
Jews as
anti-semitic that lack of moral Clarity
is simply
unacceptable you know Katie I'll start
with you uh upen and my daughter went
there undergrad and went to the law
school there upen is set to lose $100
million uh from a Ross Stevens I
understand from Stone Ridge management
good for him uh and now she's
apologizing for her testimony she had
one week to prepare for that testimony
and if they had asked the question about
any other group I doubt she would have
had the reluctance to answer the
question the calling for the genocide of
any group is a violation of the code of
conduct well it's a good thing that
they're they're pulling their money and
they're feeling some of this pain but
let's be clear these presidents are not
apologizing because they've somehow
found moral Clarity on this issue
they're apologizing because they're
losing these hundred million checks and
they're embarrassed about that part of
it not necessarily what they said when
they talk about the context I'm trying
to think about how they could get to
these answers all three of them having
the same one essentially what is the
context okay so they're in this they're
Paralyzed by The Wil Olympics on campus
so the context to them in terms of the
Dei Olympics here is that they would
think okay who's making the claim is
that person more oppressed than the
person making the claim well we don't
think that Jews are as oppressed as the
Palestinians so if the Palestinians are
making the claim and the hierarchy of
wokeness and oppressive nature then the
context is such that it's okay to make
calls for genocide because because of
this allegation that they're the people
making the calls are being oppressed
somehow whether that's true or not um
they can't just look at things in the
sense of right and wrong I think what we
saw from these University presidents was
one of the most horrific incidents that
we've seen in the history of acade
Academia uh it's an obvious answer but
because of the bubble they're living in
on these college campuses and this
hierarchy of who's going to be more
oppressed than who based on skin color
and experience rather than just treating
each other equally and judging each
other on character they've gotten
themselves in this position which again
is not because they have found some
answer they had a PR firm Reach Out read
them a statement that they then tried to
reread and now they're saying that
they're somehow sorry as their jobs are
on the line right Pete at Harvard uh
misgendering someone fat phobia
constitutes violence according to their
Title Nine but
anti-Semitism requires context why uh
why
uh well first first of all everything
Katie said is right about the hierarchy
of oppressor and oppressed and that's
the lens through which uh but at the
same time $100 million that's a drop in
the bucket for these institutions right
you it's got to reach 500 600 million
we're doing a special on Fox Nation
coming out next month called Poison Ivy
about the intricate funding nature of
these Ivy League Schools they're
basically International hedge funds who
also teach classes through a Marxist
lens uh so this these these that's why
they were so smug in front of this
committee and unwilling to answer
because it cuz they they're afraid of
the students if anything and certainly
not the donors and they're wetted to one
particular worldview and then they want
to hide behind Free Speech suddenly now
free speech is their Mantra yeah after
tell that to the conservatives and the
Christians and the white kids and
everybody else on campus who's been on
the wrong side of that woke Olympics for
the last and and so now we've gotten to
the genocide of an entire people which
is as old as time and they're they just
want more context you know there's a
sound I'd like you to listen to um
Harold by the I think it's
Harvard
president in that moment I was focused
on our University's long-standing
policies aligned with the US
Constitution which say that speech alone
is not
punishable I was not focused on but I
should have
been okay that's pens McGill and she's
saying the Constitution protected me so
I'm a graduate of pin also undergrad and
I think it's simpler than I I don't know
all about the woke Olympics I'll leave
that to you guys but what I know is if
you can't condemn terrorism if you can't
identify that uh genocide of of a
population of people is something that
you're not going to tolerate within the
policies on your campus particularly
when it's already in the policies that
you have it in your your rule book and
policy book you shouldn't be in that
role uh I I hate to say this school has
been embarrassed over the last uh the
last several weeks uh so many of my
classmates and I was one of the people
that signed the very first letter weeks
ago when President mcguill did not
respond to us about why you had uh Roger
Waters the guy who has spoken about uh
about about Israel and about Jewish
people I think in an awful way they had
him coming on the highest Jewish holiday
yam kapor and the president didn't
respond to any of us there were many of
us who were I don't give a $100 million
to University but I love my school I'm
proud of it it helped make me who I am
and I try to try to send a few nickels
back every year but I join the call and
I would only send a dollar until we had
substantive change she had an
opportunity before a congressional
committee uh to show a maturity to show
a sense of moral Clarity and she failed
to do that whatever her motivation was
coming back I um uh is is is is up to
her what I know is I don't think she's
fit to be the president of the school
and it's unfortunate uh but you have one
job when you are the President of
University when it comes to promoting
Dynamic and enthusiastic and energetic
conversations even things I disagree
with you got to make it safe for kids to
be able to share their views and for
kids to learn I'm against punishing kids
that's saw some people a friend of mine
here said he was going to put the kids'
names down and was not going to hire
them these are kids get people an
opportunity for Second Chances but the
president of the school to go before a
congressional committee and to not be
able to condemn terrorism and genocide
you're not fit to be the president of
that school boom all right Jimmy wrap it
up uh rare agreement with Harold um they
do have to for they have to fire her she
shouldn't get the grace of a resignation
because there's certain questions you
don't get a second crack at okay if
we're hiring a babysitter and we go you
going to keep the kids safe and they go
no okay if they call me back the next
day and they go actually after
reflecting on this you're not hiring
them okay so all I want to say is I have
never been prouder to have attended naso
Community College and majored in Super
Mario Brothers that I am right now
watching these ivy league dopes hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else